there's one MacBook that Apple has
refused to make over the years and just
when we thought we had it coming it did
not come out now I think that with your
guys's help along with other YouTubers
we can change Apple's mind and we do
have some hints that there's a
possibility of it coming out now here at
Max Tech we have a ton of MacBooks every
single one in total I think we have
about 12 because we need them but
there's one MacBook that I absolutely
wish that we had we are huge fans of
Apple silicon Vadim was talking about it
before it was even announced and once we
got the M1 MacBook Air it blew our minds
because of the performance because it
was fanless and because of how slim and
lightweight it was and when Apple
finally announced the 14 and 16 inch
MacBook Pros that had more powerful M1
Pro and M1 Max Graphics we were so
excited for those machines now I ordered
multiples including a 16 inch MacBook
Pro for myself expect exactly how I
wanted it but after using it for a while
I ended up returning that machine and
sticking with a 14 inch model but over
the last year I've actually been picking
up and using a 16 inch MacBook Pro even
though I didn't want to just because of
the larger display even though I didn't
need the extra performance and when the
M2 MacBook Air was released I absolutely
loved it because of how thin and light
it was and of course the performance of
the M2 Chip if you don't get that base
SSD and you upgrade the RAM for the uses
that I need it does great at photo
editing video editing with those new
updated encoders including prores it is
a dream machine but I still have to
leave it at home when I need a larger
display and when I go and take one of
those up and I take it home with me I
love it because of how it just feels in
the hand how lightweight it is and I
really wish we had a 15 inch model but
Apple has refused to ever release a
larger 15-inch MacBook Air but things
could change but before I tell you how
or why if you're a Mac User that does
any sort of work with documents
spreadsheets or slideshows on your Mac
our sponsor software keep is giving our
viewers 25 off right now instead of 20
on genuine Microsoft software like a
one-time purchase of Microsoft Office
for Mac which includes word excel and
PowerPoint now there are so many fishy
websites out there that could scam you
but software keep is a Microsoft
certified partner who sells only 100
genuine Microsoft software so you don't
have to worry which resulted in software
keep earning over 100
000 5 Star reviews they also have great
prices on other software including the
most popular antivirus software out
there and the customer service is
phenomenal with 24 7 365 customer
support where you will talk to a real
person inside of a robot so if you have
any questions they will be glad to help
so buy Microsoft Office for Mac or
anything else you need today and say 25
off their already great prices by using
the link in the description and the
coupon code Max tech25 now we've made
videos on the 15-inch MacBook Air
previously because we had leaks but of
course Apple only announced the 13 inch
model and it looks like apple just
decided not to move forward with it for
this next Generation which of course is
that M2 MacBook Air now in that video we
made a poll asking you guys if you
bought a 15 or 6 inch previously why did
you buy it and 37 of the 17 000 votes
said that they just bought it because of
the larger display with the remaining
saying they needed the extra performance
but this poll was made when we just had
the M1 MacBook Air with wheat graphics
and a Max of 16 gigs of RAM but with the
M2 MacBook Air you can get 24 gigs and
if you get 16 gigs and 512 the
performance even for photo editing and
for video editing actually Rivals the 2
000 14 inch MacBook Pro and for coders
it is just seconds behind that machine
while being a lot thinner and also
lighter less expensive and in terms of
real world battery life it also beats it
out but with the low power mode it is
much better in terms of battery life
because of the M2 chips efficiency cores
that can lower the wattage super low
compared to the M1 Pro and because of
that I absolutely love the Mt MacBook
Air but I still have to use a pro
because of the larger displays now Luke
miani recently did a video on the 16
inch MacBook Pro and the gist of it is
that it is just too big and too heavy of
course Apple did make it a lot larger
and heavier compared to the previous one
they brought back ports we have extra
performance and because of that in his
poll a lot of people just voted that
they would rather have a 14 inch if the
performance was the same because of the
size and weight that is exactly why I
want a 15-inch MacBook Air to have that
larger size have good performance great
battery life in a super thin and light
package if you compare the empty MacBook
Air to the 16 inch it is so much thinner
for the body and even standing up on the
feet it is thinner than just the main
body of the 16 inch just imagine if
Apple made a 15-inch MacBook Air they
kept the same thickness maybe the same
battery capacity and it would be that
thin it would be super light
unbelievably lightweight for example
we've done videos on the LG gram and
that thing is insanely lightweight and
the 15 inch version only weighs 2.5
pounds while the dimensions are very
similar to the 15 inch MacBook Pro this
machine wouldn't weigh that low but it
would still be incredibly lightweight
for an all-aluminum laptop so why hasn't
Apple made one of these yet and how can
you help to make it happen well as you
guys know Apple sales went up
dramatically with apple silicon they had
crazy growth and in 2021 their growth
more than doubled compared to the same
period previously so they've been making
a ton of money with people buying these
machines and if they make a 15 inch
MacBook Air that would mean that they're
giving people a large screen size but at
the same time they would have to price
it lower but I think there is good news
because for 2022 Apple themselves said
that Mac revenue is going to decline
substantially of course they didn't
release any new models right now in the
fall and people that wanted a 14 to 16
inch likely already bought one and we
also have had polls that showed that
most people cannot afford one of them 97
of buyers whereas the 16 inches twenty
five hundred dollars but Apple has been
changing their mindset with the iPhone
14 plus that was the first time that
they ever gave us a large screen phone
for less than the price of the flagship
so you can get it for less money and now
people are being a lot more cautious
with spending it does seem like we're
going into a recession so people aren't
going to be buying these 2500 machines
if they need that larger size so if
Apple releases a 15 inch model it has to
be sued and we have had some more recent
leaks about March May and June about a
new 15-inch MacBook coming out we've had
info from Ross young a display analyst
about a display coming and if apple is
going to make one now would be the
perfect time to make it now we also had
some info that it might not even be
called the MacBook Air and I think that
totally makes sense because typically
it's less expensive and it's a smaller
size they've never had a large one but a
15 inch MacBook that's also thin and
lightweight would make sense and then
they could price it not extremely low
but still much better than twenty five
hundred dollars for example the 14 plus
is about 200 cheaper but it has way less
features and with this one they could
make it say two thousand dollars or
hopefully sixteen hundred Seventeen
hundred dollars depending what the base
spec would be and give you something
that slim lightweight fanless great
performance and a lot more affordable
than twenty five hundred dollars and I
think that is going to be my dream
machine so please comment down below
comment other places on other YouTubers
channels because Apple does go out and
they do read that they read forums and
they make their decisions when I push
something back what they should make
what they don't you know taking that
information into account so let us know
if this is a machine that you'd be
interested in and how much you would be
willing to pay for this 15 inch
lightweight thin laptop thank you guys
for watching go ahead and click that
Circle above to subscribe check out one
of those great videos over there this
has been Max and I'll see you in the
next one
[Music]